well joining me now is James skeet from
just a Boyle our fellow environmental
campaigner Danica McCarthy okay uh well
I remember feeling is pretty clear
here's the problem I have with it with
this just up oil thing is that
most people agree with the issue that
you're campaigning for
most people
in the polls think there's a real
problem with climate change I'm one of
them no arguments for that but most
people in fact the vast majority now are
absolutely sick and tired of what just
stop oil are doing they think it's
pureral pathetic and it's not advancing
the cause one eye under nobody is
walking around going God they've rightly
they've wrecked the snooker I must come
round to their cause why do this stuff I
don't get it well just the transparency
peers
um you've signed a deal for 50 million
pounds for this show I don't know what
deal or so you've signed a deal for 50
minutes
who sits on the board of Genie oil and
gas
um so just for transparency just so
we're all aware that that's what I do
work for murder yes you do he owns this
network yes and he has spent decades
persuading the British people and uh
this is around the world me asking you
about the merits of wrecking regular
life for britons in this country I don't
get it for example do you support what
happened at the snooker
of course I support what happened to the
Snoop why why are you laughing I'm am I
laughing yeah you are you're smirking
and so was the guy who did the the stand
up the snooker here's my problem it's
all a bit of a game for you guys you
regularly you regularly get seen smoking
and laughing it's all a bit of fun it's
not fun for the people whose lives
you're ruining
yes
um when the last ipcc report was
released and that's basically the sound
of the world's climate scientists
banging their heads against the desks
basically in despair that no one's
listening to them that made page 11 of
the Daily Mail underneath two women
arguing over their geraniums right
as a result of what happened on Monday
our demand has been on the front of
everyone no your demand wasn't on the
front page that idiot was on the front
page millions millions of conversations
millions of conversations have been
elicited and have even attended them
um draw attention to the fact that the
British government are planning ahead
with over a hundred new fossil fuel
licenses opening new coal mines in the
middle of the worst crisis that we've
ever seen then it's a win don't you
think do you think no I don't I don't
think it's a win at all I think I think
it's a massive lose actually I think
what you're doing is alienating a public
who might well be persuaded because they
show it in the polls to come on your
side but at the moment they think you're
a bunch of annoying twerks right in my
life let me bring in uh you here
I don't understand why you can't because
you're you're not an unintelligent
person I've followed your stuff for a
few years why you can't understand that
this is backfiring why you don't get
that the British public are sick of it I
think what's really interesting here is
is that you've just spent five minutes
talking about tactics when you actually
said you are you're seriously concerned
about this issue yeah and we would
really welcome conversations on talk TV
about the issues you said you know the
British government is doing good well
actually a report came out last week
from Ram about global investment in new
fossil fuels since Copenhagen six
trillion dollars invested in new fossil
fuels 15 came from the UK okay let me
ask you something let me think okay I
think it's I'm going to give you a
follow-up question but tell me
I need to finish the point tell me the
carbon emissions that the UK and then
for China and Russia and India Britain
is investing 15 of the global investment
in fossil fuels globally which according
to the International Energy agency
according to in the European Investment
Bank and even HSBC are saying we do not
need investing seven trillion dollars
over the next 10 years is a suicide note
for Humanity okay so bad so you say uh
uh but I'll ask you again so do the
world scientists okay yes but there is
actually a very debatable uh response
from the sand it's about exactly the
best way to tackle this because I would
listen to a woman for example on Nick
Ferrari Sean LBC the other day saying
that within eight years if we stopped
awarding any licenses now we'd have
eight more years of gas and oil and then
she said we could actually sustain this
country for all the power we need from
wind and waves that's what we're saying
it's completely unworkable there is
nobody with a brain who has managed to
work out a way so that could possibly be
done in eight years do you actually so
so you guys are living do you believe
you guys are living here sorry cheers
are you saying the European Investment
Bank HSBC the International Energy knows
more than you because that what I am
saying is quoting them I'm not saying
that no more than me no I'm saying they
are actually saying that we can't invest
in new fossil fuels because we've got
nothing
in my estimation the sensible way to do
this is to move slowly off fossil fuels
to renewable energy yes to make it
affordable and make it practical that's
why we don't have half the country
turned into win funds that's the
sensible way to do this right and I'm up
for that sensible debate that's not why
you two were booked on this show you two
were booked on this show because the
methods that you're you're using in my
opinion are now damaging your cause they
are actually deterring the public for
supporting you and again I ask you why
do it why wait for the snooker why go
and shops why go and do these stupid why
is the government investing massive
amounts and new fossil fuels when the
Nia says we can't afford it right why is
the government saying one thing you're
playing what a battery my question is my
question is core to this issue right
you're talking about it no of powder and
I'm talking about building I'm talking
about you being destroying I'm talking
about you being on a destructive mission
to piss off the public and in my long
time in the media I can tell you it's
not going to work the very fact that
we're having this conversation is a
testament to the efficacy of these
things
if you're sophisticated opinion about
climate change everything brought up
you've been brought some because you're
idiot friends have been once again
wrecking things for people the fact of
the matter is that we're seeing that the
only real leverage that normal people
have is through disruptive tactics right
the nurses know it the train drivers
know it the junior doctor so why don't
you go where the real polluters are why
don't you go to Beijing because we
wanted to go to Russia
telling people what to do you are moral
cowards your moral cowards it's easier
to go and ruin an old granny's day at
The Crucible than it is to get on a
plane and go to Beijing
the eighth biggest emitter historically
we have to get our own house in order
before we go around the world lecture
I've asked I've asked I've asked you and
I'll ask you what do you think
why don't you go to Sudan hang on why
don't you go to Pakistan interview the
people whose life okay
listen and use your amazing rules it
could be courageous just to verify it's
not your show no but shout out I do work
I do the question do you do this stop
shouting at me then you have an answer
my conversation let's have a question
that's good see if you can answer it
what are the CO2 emissions for this
country and what are they for China and
Russia and India per capita the United
Capital what are the emissions China's
what percentage of the emissions in the
world are you come from China you think
China using childish maths is silly
childish math a statistical fact because
no a country that's bigger than UK what
percentage of the global emissions come
from China production emissions are
consumption just give me the emissions
you are actually those are two very
different things you're so expert and
everybody
you're asking this question because it
wasn't the answer what I am saying is
China is 20 times bigger in population
the UK so its admissions are 20 times
bigger but our investments are 15 times
when are you going to Beijing when you
go to to Sudan
amazing can we can we agree I'll put you
guys on a plane tomorrow to Beijing I'll
pay right people are you going to go and
protests
what will it actually take
I just think you guys are honestly
moronic in the way you're going about
this if you want to go today
Pakistan come with us to Sudan and talk
to them talk to people who are dying how
are you going to get there this is the
usual yeah you just invited me to
Beijing and I said I'll go there how are
you going to get this I will fly to
Pakistan okay so you believe in flights
that's a child well you've been I don't
fly for holidays to you you've been on
you apply for holidays you've been on
National Television I'll watch this
interview you went on my own program
Good Morning Britain and you you
actually said you wanted everyone to get
rid of their pets you are the great pets
Lord you want to fly take a look let's
take a look do you fly for a holiday say
hello you're just playing the person not
not the actual issues when are you human
beings as well I mean it's it's one
thing to give up your car but you're not
going to give up a loved member of your
family which frankly is what people
consider cats and dogs
well if we love our members of our
family if we love our kids do you have
to accept we have to look after the
climate crisis
firstly I want to look after my kids and
my pets that's what that's quite
shopping
that's quite shocking do you understand
the level of prices that the carbon
emissions are currently in the planet we
all think I shouldn't be looking after
my children and my pets
I'm saying that to look after and love
your children you have to look after
your carbon emissions people dying in
Sudan and the people drowning just to be
clarified no one can hear you and but
that was airing uh that was you saying
we should all get rid of our pets
do you stand by that hang on let him
answer you said that on national TV but
I stand by you stand by we should all
get rid of our standby such you should
look at the women who are dying in Sudan
do you answer questions you ask the
question I'm here for journalism when
you're not hacking into murder
children's funds oh okay so
unfortunately you've just committed a
very serious libel because that was
another newspaper which if you were
slightly more intelligent and well
informed you would have known that
allegation which is made against me most
days on Twitter by idiots like you is
actually a disgusting lie so here's your
chance to now apologize for a disgusting
lie are you prepared to do that
absolutely not okay well then I would if
I were you I'd have a chat with your
lawyers after the show and see how they
React to what you think so do you think
we should be having grown-up
conversation about it
well I don't think steering I don't
think just feeling disgusting the family
lies about something that I had nothing
to do well it's actually what I was
called grown-up situation I agree you
want to talk about great situation
emotions reality of what's Happening
Here I'm not asking you I've got four
children and you don't if you could like
if you could sit back what I think
you've said enough for the last five
minutes uh-huh let me ask you like it do
you stand by your claim that we should
get rid of all the pets I I did not ever
say that I didn't say it I was actually
that it was actually I'm not an
irrelevant discussion you think that's
irrelevant to a nation of pet love hang
on I did not say that first of all and
secondly trying to play the billions of
things
have you ever watched you want to save
the human beings and get rid of all the
million people would displaced last time
60 UK families lost their houses in
wildfires there's a result of 25 000
wildflowers when we hit 40 degrees and
you're not emotionally connecting with
the reality of this at all I'm obviously
connecting with you I think
you do your little silly sound bites for
Twitter and Twitter goes oh look at my
little hero where's the rest of the
public watching go is who is this little
brat I wish those guys that jump on
snooker tables it's those guys that ruin
the ground now it's those guys that do
all this stuff
do you want to try and get in because
this guy's just I think he's gonna be
really useful rather than actually all
of us in indulging in personal attacks
is if we could have a serious battle
invite the oil companies in here Pierce
but you understand how hard it is right
serious debate when you write it it's
like in the old time feeling this kind
of stuff inviting the old companies
unfortunately James you are a complete
what's the evidence could you
accept that the evidence is what the
viewers have been watching they just
think
and you're talking about stuff I
actually do wonder I actually do wonder
what kind of humanity would be left if
people like you were the only ones left
honestly it would be like a place I mean
a place where you're not allowed pets
that's the place where people like you
are running the country I would
literally rather die anyway it's been
lovely catching up thank you very much
for your time